le sénat l'institution du sénat y tel
est le mode d'élection et elle sait dire
quand même très archaïque et très
ringard un bon que on est un peu obligé
de mettre sur les listes soient comme
tête de liste soit dans une autre
position
les personnalités du parti politique les
plus connues dans le département parce
qu'il faut que ces grands électeurs
les maires et conseillers municipaux les
conseillers départementaux tout ça ils
sont un peu dans le même monde
il faut que se reconnaissent que voilà
si vous mettez des gens qui sont très
bien qu'ils sont dynamiques star mais
qui sont des illustres inconnus parmi le
personnel politique d'un département
vous risquez d'avoir moins de chance moi
j'ai fait de nombreuses sénatoriales en
province notamment dans le département
de l'aisne
ben c'est tout un petit monde je ne sais
pas si vous à paris vous ira peut-être
mais la salle du des fêtes de l'hôtel de
ville pendant toute la journée de
dimanche
ça va être le microcosme politicien
parisien qui va serrer se réunir mais
qui va voter mais qu'il est 37 d'entre
eux soit et nous on front national à
paris on a beaucoup de mal à être
accepté en province pour être acceptée
il faut essayer de pousser municipal
d'une petite ville où maire d'une ville
ou conseiller départemental et alors là
on est un peu plus comme un poisson dans
l'eau
c'est ça les élections sénatoriales
c'est compte tenu du mode de scrutin
très particulier et 2 et 2 et de
l'existence très particulière du sénat
tel qu'il existe encore à l'heure
actuelle